welcome to the Microsoft translator hub
video on the training process this
section assumes that you already have
created a project and invited members to
participate for more information on
those topics refer to the online help
and watch the other videos that will
guide you through those processes to
begin a training process go to the
project page by clicking on projects and
then manage projects in the upper right
hand corner click on the project for
which you'd like to create a training in
order to open the project details page
for that specific project from there
click on add training you may give your
training a name or use the
auto-generated name notice the use
microsoft models checkbox if your
language is supported by a Microsoft
translator and this box is checked the
training will leverage the existing
translation models this can make your
translations more accurate and more
fluent now before you begin training
you'll need to upload your assemble set
of parallel documents and monolingual
documents click the add documents link
here at the right browse your documents
and then click upload documents can
include Microsoft Office Word documents
Adobe Acrobat files
TMX HTML and text file formats it's
important to note that txt files must be
encoded in unicode either utf-16 or
utf-8 to check the encoding for text
files click the save as button in your
text editor such as notepad and check to
make sure that the encoding is set
either to Unicode or utf-8 documents can
only be uploaded one at a time so if you
have a large number of documents to
upload we suggest that you archive them
in a zip GZ or tgz file
Microsoft translator hub will extract
the documents validate them remove any
formatting and images so you can upload
monolingual and parallel documents
separately or together parallel
documents will be paired so only one
file name appears in the list of loaded
documents you'll be able to see if the
document is monolingual or parallel by
looking here in the type column now
take a look at the three tabs on the
training page the training tab the
tuning tab and the testing tab first
let's look at the training tab once
you've uploaded your documents they will
appear here you can sort the files using
the column headers you can see the
extracted sentences by clicking in the
number on the sentence column at the
bottom of the table you'll see a summary
of the data that has been uploaded the
number of parallel sentences and the
number of parallel and monolingual
documents next let's look at the tuning
tab data you select for tuning data
should be a collection of parallel
sentences that strictly adheres to the
expected output for the target language
this set enables the system to tune a
translation model which will provide
optimal results by keeping the tuning
set constant it is possible to compare
the quality of the systems accuracy as
you conduct trainings with different
training datasets and calibrate and
select training data to better suit your
needs if you leave the default setting
of auto microsoft translator hub will
randomly select approximately 5% of the
data with a minimum of 500 sentences and
a maximum of 2,000 sentences from the
training data set as tuning data as the
data increases so will the number of
selected tuning sentences making the
quality comparison between different
training runs difficult you can freeze
the tuning set by manually selecting a
document to tune the results of your
training this is done by selecting the
manual select option and then clicking
the radio button next to your preferred
tuning document this can be undone by
clicking auto select tuning data finally
let's take a look at the testing tab the
testing data is a collection of parallel
sentence that is used to test the
quality of the translations therefore
like tuning it should also adhere to the
proper terminology of the expected
output steps should be taken to ensure
that this file contains unique sentences
that are not exact duplicates of
training or tuning data this set is used
to validate
the translation model and is the base
reference used to compute blue scores
blue which is short for bilingual
evaluation under study is a metric that
measures how closely automatic
translation matches a human created
reference translation a higher blue
score indicates that a particular
training has produced better
translations like the tuning tab
automatic selection is default you can
manually override that by selecting a
document or set of documents that
contains representative parallel
sentences of your expected output for
more information on best practices for
training tuning and testing visit the
help section of this site